[Musik]
eltern von kindern mit behinderungen
tragen eine schwere bürde
oftmals ist es aber weniger ihr
schicksal dass diese familien belastet
sondern die querelen mit
invalidenversicherung
bei mir ist das sage ich das
ja eigentlich die größte bucht für
dieses oder frauen vertrauen mit liefer
lösungen zu finden
verschnupft und das wort und kochen
ja
york entschieden nach außen eher voraus
planen wir sind und den terror
[Musik]
segment sie ist fünfeinhalb jahre alt
seit seiner geburt ist er körperlich und
kognitiv schwer beeinträchtigt
jetzt einfach nur weg jetzt bin ich
wollte
was den körper nach berechtigung
das lager war wahrscheinlich die rechte
tarvis klemm dort repressionen
überspannung
das heißt laufen
schnitt einfachere
erst letztes jahr lernt laufen also
eigentlich ist sie
sehr clever august hat sich wieder
gefangen das ist ein paar schritte
gemacht und den september oktober zog
sie das wirklich auf uns langsam
geschafft hat zum grünen laufen und der
im oktober führte war dass er jetzt gut
wie fix ii bis man endlich kennenlernen
laufen
patrick kann gehen für dieses wunder
haben er und seine mutter hasst
gearbeitet
du machst dann wird zahlt oder wollte
sie da nicht gern
was sind das für medikamente das
antiepileptikum und satirisches katar
brisant ich lösche wieder so die
verspannung sehr stark alt und das dort
muskelentspannung ist eigentlich das
blutdruck sein konzept
aber wir hatten auch gerne versoffen
muskelverspannungen gesetzt
ursprünglich sei
zum beispiel sehr wahrscheinlich wird
mir reden hier laufen und
hat sehr stark sehr gelähmt im rollstuhl
hoch dass so die ursprüngliche prognose
kann keine sicherheit
zum schutz vor der erz denke mal
unterhalten riesige hirnschaden also das
lager fasst
halbe hier eine komplett verloren und
der 2c trial und thalfang
abgestorben ist
und immer wenn aufgrund rein für den
mann auf dem kopf aber halt verloren hat
ist klar es sind prognosen alles nicht
wirklich gut
ob sie trägt die ersten tage nach seiner
geburt überleben würde war mir als
ungewiss noch im bauch seiner mutter
charlotte nc hat er einen ersten
schlaganfall kurz vor der geburt einen
zweiten seine mutter punkte allein um
sein leben noch während der
schwangerschaft hatte sie sich von
patricks vater getrennt
[Musik]
brutale beförderungsmittel mit dem
gedanken auf wasser hat dennis frank
schaff studer selber und enya irgendwo
bestimmten punkt logistics ist alles auf
die zug und da scheint es nun angst und
panik
rücklichter dass ich es mit ihm als 7
und in warschau geboren ist irgendwie so
ich wollte man sich am zweiten tag aus
bewusst sich so scheiße du musst es
jetzt zwei mehr ist du bist alles waren
halt du nur du bist das mami und
errichte sind egal was er hat
grund da den
gnadenlosen
selina mit neun jahre alt
selina schlaft und sicher so grünzweig
zigarren
selina lebt mit ihren eltern und dem
kleinen bruder dario in luzern
dass wir jetzt
mit tara hanke
selina hat das rett syndrom die
krankheit führt zu einer
entwicklungsstörung des
zentralnervensystems
selina kann wieder selbstständig sitzen
noch gehen noch sprechen betroffen vom
rett syndrom sind nur mädchen die
diagnose von isabel und toni mutter als
celina zwei jahre alt war
sie es sich mit entdecken der tiefe
krankheit das bedeutet dass es immer
schlechter wird und bis zum tod wird
sondern es ist ein neurologischer
erkrankungen michael dahms in automaten
wenn wir was sie mit mir mit anderen
kindern spielen die gedanken sich
gemacht und ihre aufgabe ist einfach
glücklich zu machen
segment sie hat einen kleinen bruder den
dreijährigen syrien
er selber wird seit seinem dritten
lebensmonat in den verschiedensten
therapien gefördert und seine
fortschritte verbunden sein umfeld und
die ärzte doch trotz alledem cedric
bleibt schwer beeinträchtigt und hat
mühe sich zu konzentrieren
wilson
[Musik]
fz38
schwierig mit dem
tisch des jahres persönlich finde dass
ist wichtiges nerven und glauben
immer erwähnt wird dass ein spielt
momentan messe
er seit jahren konzentrierter im haus
heute ersttherapie gelernt
patrick held seit seiner geburt eine
hilflosenentschädigung der
invalidenversicherung
als es darum ging diese leistungen zu
erhöhen kam ein vertreter der iv zu
schauen ob menschen nach hause der
augenschein vor ort ein traumatisches
erlebnis
also die
löhne
wären nach einer riesenportion geschöpft
doch nun bitte unter dem motto nach
erschöpft und der bereits den sack
fanghandschuh bund jetzt sprichwörtlich
rechten arm beschriebenen gestanden das
ist mit
richtige täglich zu messen das problem
ist der trümmer landtag hat der
medikamente
und er braucht einfach essen vor dem sv
bermatingen
und
und ich finde einfach mehr
vergesse ich einfach nicht mit ihm einig
und das ist verletzend wird island über
dich aber die sind für die stunden 23
[Musik]
es wird schwierig vor dem der landtag
wie man es aus mache für die iv sei es
nie richtig desire lebensgefühl sagt sie
tricks mutter weil sie schwer mitmachen
und mitsingen die krebs und dann musste
ich noch mit so sachen abgewählt und
wenn dieses kriegs und werde sich so
jeder wünscht müsste studierte kein
stress keine dato
charlottes ist im dritten monat
schwanger
angst dass ihr drittes kind ebenfalls
mit einer behinderung geboren werden
könnte habe sie keine sagt die 39
jährige
unter der woche ist charlotte nc
praktisch alleinerziehend ihr partner
der vater des kleinen syrien und des
ungeborenen kindes ist stoffe und von
früh morgens bis spät in die nacht
unterwegs
allein ist sie darum auch oft mit ihrer
verzweiflung über die iv zum beispiel
wegen des langen wartens auf die
kostengutsprache für einen reha autositz
mit kopfstütze auf den sektor dringend
angewiesen ist
abgelehnt worden
weil irgendwie entstanden ist weckt kopf
kontrolle militärischen barrett und
aufgrund von der eigenen controller
werden abgelehnt und der nährstoff grund
vom zweite rezept ist in österreich in
der sitz zu gesprochen worden und es ist
eine kurzform nach der heimat überhaupt
termine anfangs jahr es ist einfach ja
es macht einfach worden und es ist
schafft er will es ja nicht wenn man das
gefühl hat man muss es jetzt um es vor
dem grafen sich selber sondern weil sie
als 40 halbhoch ihn
ja als ich rot muss erhalten strich aber
bis das letzte signal dafür schon
erfahren
was heißt grün
los genau
charlotte sie ist nicht mehr berufstätig
zu kräfteraubend sind sie tricks
betreuung und pflege
einmal pro woche bringt sie die beiden
buben für zwei stunden zu einer
tagesmutter in dieser zeit geht sie
einkaufen oder gönnt sich eine stunde im
fitnesscenter
aber es wirkt lässig das ganze ja das
einfache
weltmeister dieser woche mit dem spital
stiftung cerebral einen antrag gestellt
dass er wenigstens zwei woche zwei
stunden
entlastungsdienst
relativ hoch ist mit
vertrauen erblich bedingt das wirklich
viel abverlangt ist und da das inntal
wachsen und jetzt vorstand und
drehstrom ist man selber zahlen und so
weitere kräfte zur weniger oder so klar
aber es wird er nennt den vertrieb
schmitz wir dann halt wirklich um das
lied hat sind am 10
und es
bestätigt ist das noch
heute pflegt eine mitarbeiterin der
kinder spitex erinnerte
sich wolfgang piest mal luft celina oben
lagen aus dass wir ihm mit regelmäßig
machen damit sie nicht sehr viele
stunden auf der gleichen seite liegt und
nach eine druckstelle berühmt und ja
jedes windeln gewechselt und zweimal die
maschine
verladen ton und die maschine nach das
einfach besser diese stoffe sorgen
bekommen berlin als pflege nimmt jeden
tag im minimum sechs stunden in anspruch
zwei bis dreimal pro woche unterstützen
pflegefachfrauen der in der spitex
isabel hatte dass ich sehr groß hier
leer also eine sitze wie es im takt und
dabei zum beispiel
personal
training dass er voll und ganz auf die
spitex verlage womit der selina medis
gtz
und der nacht wie sie ab und zu erkennen
dass sie einfach mal eine nacht
durchschlafen
berlin als mutter ist ebenfalls
pflegefachfrau mit ihrer berufserfahrung
konnte sie selina schon manchen
spitalaufenthalte sparen
sie macht das mit sehr viel feingefühl
sorgfalt und
liebe also vivio wie jedes mal meine
tochter würde pflege
wenn selina in der heilpädagogischen
schule und dario im kindergarten sind
kämpft sich isabell mutter durch den
bürokratischen dschungel mit der iv um
eine definitiven kostengutsprache für
die leistungen der kinder spitex kämpfen
isabell werth und ihr waren schon
jahrelang
musik und
17.30 dass mir so viele stunden bis
jetzt hilfe braucht dass es eben noch
beantworte ich dass wir bald in so viele
stunde trifft panthers und die tanke tv
viele stunden group ist wo so
offensichtlich ist und das ist das land
über eine lange
zeitspanne hinweg ziehen ich danke
meiner sicht rar in der infanterie fonds
mit 44 jahren
gleich dass ich einfach zu viel papier
ist bezeugt das x600 dokument zur zeit
führte vorhanden es zur bisher zweifache
in eine realistische derzeit können
abgewickelt werden
die iv des kantons luzern beurteilten
fall selina matter als außergewöhnlich
vielschichtig und
süßere beurteilung ist es nicht vier
georg aber ich danke musste sich vor der
familien da und auch israel schätze hat
sie dem sehr komplexe sehr aufwendige
fall
ortslandwirt mit dem diese 4000 schuldig
wir sind aber der meinung dass man dann
immer werde die leistung sieht guten
können
gebrauchtwagen jetzt in zeiten immer
wieder mit mit triefender mann entnahm
josef stift und papier sind
mitarbeiter
die frau von musiker finden und das sind
einfach nur zehn geburten
ja wo man sich nicht vorstellen dass
tatsache ist dass familien wog hin zur
betreuung der ganz verschiedene leistet
jetzt gut kennt und tier ps betragen und
mit prüfen abklären ob die leistungen
dürfe der brauchte die leistungen zahlen
und einfach sagen das thema tier und die
modalitäten mit salat einfach und das
habe zu viel das aber unterschiedliche
beurteilungen einstellt unterschiedliche
blickwinkel sind berücksichtigen und das
führte dazu dass man das nicht immer
raus nur partnerschaftlich
beurteilen
trotz alledem ihre erfahrungen mit der
iv seien keineswegs nur negativ sagt
isabel matter
hilfsmittel umbauten und therapien
bezahle die iv anstandslos
die sich immer gut das vergessen dass
ich schon so und und ob man wirklich ist
und dass man wenn das metall ist mit
lediglich
8 lagen
auch die fahrtkosten zu allen therapien
und arztbesuchen werden von der iv
übernommen und isabell materie ist viel
mit selina unterwegs also pro jahr so
kombiniert mit arzttermin physio
hilfsmittel etc diese rund 100 termine
pro jahr
einer davon die regelmäßige anpassung
von sally das orthesen die verhindern
dass ihre gliedmaßen sich verkürzen oder
verformen
die kamera zeigt dass es zusammen mit
der wechsel in
europa morgen
die andere
um infektionen jeder atemwege zu
verhindern muss salina mehrmals täglich
inhalieren
multitasking
zwischen wenigen ist eben werden
nacheinander machen wird
mit den leuten mario
mira schönholzer zweieinhalb jahre alt
schon immer aus der schon zwei monaten
bemerkte die kinderärztin das mit mir
aus muskelaufbau etwas nicht stimmte
bald stellte sich auch heraus dass wir
damit den reizen aus ihrer umwelt nicht
klarkommt dies führte zu bisweilen
wochen langen schrei phasen die bis
heute anhalten
verzögerung wo man macht sich im moment
du für einen stand folgt also zwischen
halbjährig und jährig so es selbst die
relativ wieder als elektrischer stück
lesen damit der gründliche hat hunger
mit dem bradley wo sie schon stücke aber
frei 17 oder sollten für sie noch nicht
in frage auch kommunikation ist mit
ihnen recht schwierig ich verstanden bei
dem sein was sie will ich höre morath
dollar bezahlt heißt ja es passt aber
was jetzt genau das nicht passt kann die
verhandlung kommunikation zu
woran mira genau leidet wissen christina
schönholzer und immer nicht
trotz ihrer offensichtlichen
beeinträchtigung liegt keine diagnose
firma aus behinderung vor darum hat die
iv ihre zahlungen an familie schönholzer
eingestellt keine diagnose keine iv
ziffer für geburtsgebrechen keine
leistung und für mira die iv des kantons
thurgau ihm dort zu nur schriftlich
stellung die invalidenversicherung
konnte die beeinträchtigungen von mira
auch nach eingehender sachverhalts
prüfung keine anderweitigen gebrechens
ziffer zu ordnen als rechtliche
konsequenz verweigerte die
invalidenversicherung ab mir als drittem
lebensjahr die übernahme von
medizinischen maßnahmen inklusive der
dazugehörenden behandlungsgeräte und
therapien
diese antwort raubtier auch christina
schönholz zu den orten
das ist einfach so gesamtsituation war
riesig belastend ist einerseits dass man
nicht weiß wie jetzt wieder woanders
sitzt das halt einfach wirklich von
morgen bist so wird streng ist uns nacht
verbrachte zimmer auch noch zwei drei
mal unter umständen doch keine so
richtige aber fahrer und auch sie ab
gehe ich natürlich fast unmöglich mal
der tag durch sicher darauf ja stunde
ist kein problem aber jemals nacht wird
einmal einfach ein acht stunden schlafe
der schon bisher sehr belastet
die krankenkasse übernimmt wohl die
kosten für die medizinischen maßnahmen
leistungen wie die vergütung von
fahrtkosten oder die finanzierung von
therapien geräten bleiben den schön
holzes aber verwehrt
das ist eben lieber sitzen bliebe
für ihre weitere entwicklung bräuchte
mira dringend ein schneebrett um ihre
umwelt auch aus einer aufrechten
perspektive wahrnehmen zu können
doch dafür fühlen sich weder
krankenkasse noch ev zuständig recht
abstützen
unterstützen und
so ich gut und ich dass christina dass
das trotzdem verweigert ich möchte zu
erzielt
ja ich habe eine schwierige frage die
horste zu wort denn auch er heißt
einfach so hin zu mehr zahlt sowieso
nicht
dem therapie stuhl den mira unter
anderem zum essen am tisch benötigt
beantragten schönholz sich noch vor mir
als zweiten geburtstag
sollten anpassungen nötig werden müsste
die familie diese selbst beraten und
mira wächst und wird schwer bald wird
sie nicht mehr in diesen therapie stuhl
passen
das tor makaay das nervt mich total und
das ist ein
ok vor schluss ein loch arbeitszeit also
das braucht wahnsinnig viel energie die
ganze bürokratie und sei aus unwissen
also es ist sehr komplex und das müssten
sich zuerst mal eigene und hier voll und
die herforder ist heute ja auch schritt
wollte mithilfe schwierig zum
informationen finden
mit hilfe eines gentests soll jetzt eine
diagnose für mir aus behinderung
gefunden werden damit sie zu einer iv
ziffer und so zu iv leistungen kommt die
chancen dass der gentest eine diagnose
liefern kann liegen bei 60 prozent
familie schönholzer wird durch den
rechtsdienst der
selbsthilfeorganisation broker vertreten
fälle wie dieser sind oft zu kompliziert
zu kräfteraubend und bisweilen auch
emotional zu belastend aus dass sie ohne
rechtsbeistand zu bewältigen wählen das
kind mit behinderung wo sehr viel
zeitaufwand bedeutet wo man ganz viel
hobby und freizeit und und und
partnerschafts anleger muss hinten
anstellen und aus dessen dürfen wir in
einer zahle dafür das ist durchaus
extrem ungerecht aber im gesetz geregelt
wo die wamu sie halten das motiv ein
schutz nahm wenn es möglichst grad
notwendig gebots gebracht dem uefa pläne
schnitt der vater vor der ifa fahrer von
der gesetzgebung und das liegt wiederum
und man könne das gesetz erst andere
wenn man dort zu verbuchen aber mehrheit
ist gut
alles gut
du darfst war halle weil es schon mal
dass du möchte ich trage hat weil es
macht bestimmt lecker
das
sind
ausnahmen
metastase lina mutter leidet unter
nächtlichen atemaussetzern außerdem kann
eine einfache infektion der atemwege
brandgefährlich für sie werden selina
könnte ersticken darum gehört das
einrichten des überwachungsgeräte zu
salinas allabendliche routine
[Musik]
mit jedoch musikalisch
stadt vor im musik
[Musik]
interpretiert das ziel in etwa sieht mir
die schuld einfach gemacht dass sie
endlich laufen
will ich finde das schön dass zellen die
fähigkeit hat ist das mitteilen
jetzt ist also eine serielle und das
verstehe die einzige was ich jetzt stehe
ich vor jeder dass sie das haar
salina spiels mit legitimem hält
unterstütze ich mein glück momentan
traktors auf sehr viel verzichtet das
nehme ich mir alles darauf dass
austria so weller aber der martini rein
dass nur eine spielstation ev ist seriös
seriöser partner ist und nicht semantik
karl durchschnitten und bescheinigt
einfach ein guter partner ist eine gute
mannschaft ist die grundhaltung ist mit
menschen für mitmenschen das heißt dass
man miteinander auf der welt aber die
trostrunde beurteilen wie viel
pflegeleistungen welchem umfang wir
gesehen dass delta sehr viel machen mir
auch klar was ein sitz gut was machen
spitex was macht also stand was macht
familie und dass man da am schluss nicht
zum gleichen ergebnis und immer zum
gleichen ergebnis und ich leide tatsache
und das kann man nicht verhindern aber
es ist nicht so dass wir
familien würden scharfe wohnen ganz
großen hof an der bringt für tochter
ja
das bso resistance in charlottes alltags
tricks anstrengendes art ritual
machen picknick christoph tropp enorm
sorg bitte machen sie muss neben ihrem
schweren geschädigt sind so und so lange
liegen bleiben bis diese eingeschlafen
ist sonst nimmt kein ende mehr
nach über einer stunde endlich ruhe in
der zwischenzeit ist auch charlottes
partner nach hause gekommen
einfach geschafft
und jetzt nach einem langen tag
formulare für die iv ausfüllen
wäre dem kriegen dummer sehe könnte ich
mich ganz darauf konzentrieren das ist
für
mich mit dem bist du nur den verstand
abgelenkt und
dann passieren fehler
und als ob ihre arbeit der brust
konzentration wirklich fürs büro
es geht auch nicht wieso der nhl macht
ja sowas ist mitunter hat geld wofür
hält
ja
und ich müsste
[Musik]
jetzt immer machen jetzt die schreiben
zu erheben
mir hat ihr stimmrecht erhalten
ihre eltern haben es gebraucht in
deutschland gefunden ein happy end mit
bitterem nachgeschmack der verein
sterntaler ist für iv und krankenkasse
eingesprungen und hat familie
schönholzer die kosten für das dringend
benötigte therapiegerät erstattet
moment und tiere mit sehr viel peter und
das stimmt es einfach die ganze familie
positiv und mithin aber trotz gesund
sind und mit der selina das kostet wir
sind glücklich und sind so viele sachen
teil sie strahle zählt freut uns das
geht so viel zurück
und nach einem jahrelangen rechtsstreit
mit der iv hat familie mutter nun auch
endlich die kostengutsprache für die
kinder spitex erhalten es ist krank dass
selena ist die familie der firma wir
können das bewältigen
[Musik]